alors julien qu'est ce qu'on boit
délicieux sellama sac et non masqué aux
fraises des bonnes fraises bio du québec
en plus le temps des fraises c'est une
boisson sucrée naturellement riche en
11e qui est une base pour faire des
soucis de yo gourd des soldes bref
quelqu'un qui remplace très bien le yoga
la crème sur le lait j'ai l'impression
bois du kéfir ouais ben oui ça donne
l'impression le petit côté acidulé issu
de la fermentation de la masa qui
donnent eux rappelle un petit peu le
yoga ou le kéfir mais on est vraiment
ailleurs deux points de vue la
fermentation le seuil est pas de
produits laitiers là dedans ce massacre
et c'est dans l'univers du coe j
mais qui est le cojc une incubation de
champignons sur du grain généralement on
va le faire avec du riz ça vient du
japon comme technique puisque ça fait ça
vient vraiment riche en usine ça vient
rendre les sucres complexes l'amidon
ensuque simplifiée donc ça donne un
petit goût sucré naturellement julien
clos fabrique du thème paix et du kimchi
qu'ils vont au marché de val david
il y a quatre ans il a découvert l'amas
sac et est très facile en fait feu kurt
on rit moi je fais cuire le riz avec
plus d'eau en gros jamais voulu admettre
deux tasses d'eau partage de riches mais
trop tard tout moi j'utilise le riz
arborio bio d'italie qui était un record
en rien les autos à ce moment j'étais en
train de mélanger de riz qui est cuit ce
matin puis qui étaient refroidis à bonne
température
yvonne température c'est une température
ce qui est maintenait mandat vous savez
la température est idéale pour acheter
ta petite poudre est de kôji puis fois
que c'est fait on mélange biens ont
baissé dans un pot avec le couvercle on
peut laisser cette température pièce
mais on peut aussi le mettre au four la
lumière allumée
je laisse au canal 8 à 12 heures trop ce
mot doux julien prépare différentes
versions damas à quai au sarrasin à
l'avoine et le classique au riz est là
si on veut faire ça simple à la maison à
part de vue d'une attaque et classique
ouais puis on se fait un petit 1 petits
spots et comme on dit tout à fait si on
a des bleuets sauvages puis un petit jus
d'orange maison on y voit
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi délicieux c'est toi
c'est un super petit cocktail d'été les
sens
c'est la marque qui concentrait ses
lettes u 1 comme duel soya notamment
parce que ses comptes en retrait la
sommelière nico fuji tas nous a rapporté
du japon un concentré d'un massacré un
produits introuvables ici parce qu'on
peut traquer se concentrer et fabriqué
simplement à base de riz et de koji cojc
notre champignons nationale du japon et
donc c'est une champignons qui fait là
sa qualification c'est à dire le
l'amidon du riz et le change en glucose
s'est donc fait devient sucre santé
le côté sucré mais très doux très de
trait rond très enveloppant cette boue
du riz aux salins que ton très très
douce très agréable jusqu'au deuxième
cycle c'était une boisson de luxe était
réservé pour les aristocrates
mais à partir de l'époque edo donc après
xviie siècle sur tout il est devenu
populaire parmi les gens ordinaires
maintenant il est redevenu très
populaire au japon parce que il contient
beaucoup de choses inutiles tive moi
j'écoutais de surprises
masaaki yaourt végétale à la japonaise
nous avons invité nico a goûté la
matraque et de julien clos je regarde
ont voulu goutier ressemble aux halles à
massac est du japon bah la tête tu sais
c'est tout à fait à la japonaise
[Musique]
une grande réussite est très fidèle à la
méthode de jacques lendemain
écoute vous avez une surprise pour moi
oui là j'ai apporté du japon vous qui a
la main jacques alors c'est comme des
produits dérivés damas à quai au qui
veut dire petit bâton
[Rires]
tu crées c'est délicieux comme un petit
bonbon
[Musique]